while chaos erupted on capitol hill
local trump supporters marched in
different parts of town
continuing our team coverage sasha
loftis heard from some around town
with differing views of today's events
[Music]
brian while all protests here remained
peaceful locally
many trump supporters here in las vegas
wanted to make their voices heard
we did speak to some though that say
things have just gone too far
both in washington d.c and here in las
vegas
[Applause]
as the world watches america i thought
it was
you know really crazy but we had never
seen this
in our country las vegas share their
thoughts on a day
we'll never forget i think that they
need to get that under wraps
like somebody died today it's crazy
after an angry mob of president trump
supporters
stormed the u.s capitol wednesday
peaceful protests
followed here in the valley
all in an effort to stop the
certification of president-elect
joe biden's election this election is
fraudulent
so we're not going to put up with it
we're not going to allow it to go
through
there is still no evidence of widespread
voter fraud
but groups from las vegas to washington
d.c
say they won't back down until they make
their message clear
it's such a simple fair message nothing
radical
nothing extreme about it while others
here at home believe the president
and those who back him have gone too far
he's causing the issues like you know
today at the his rally
let's march down to the capitol
and just kind of fueled what had
happened today
they hope our city and country can come
back
from what many call an overwhelming
conflict
the country definitely is split and not
in a good way
today's stop the steel protests started
here outside the federal courthouse
downtown
then they moved this afternoon to the
clark county election headquarters in
north las vegas and again all
events here did remain peaceful for now
reporting live downtown sasha loftis
8 news now